Be Open to experience,
be willing to try new things.
Don't have a rigid plan except random
acts of hospitality without judgment or
fear.
Don't be afraid to wander.
Don't be afraid to eat a bad meal.
You know,
if you don't risk the Bab Neil,
you'll never get the magical one,
but are the most important to be humble.
Be grateful.
Be Aware of the fact that you are
probably the stupidest person in the
room as far as you were the least
prepared,
at least equipped person to know who's
really in charge of what's really going
on.
I think I made maybe before I started
traveling,
I thought that the human race as a whole
or you know,
could,
could and would turn on itself at any
moment.
You know,
Venal petty,
cruel,
arbitrary,
and it's true with all of those things
exist in this world,
but I need mostly pretty nice people
doing the best they can.
Often under very,
very difficult conditions.
I met a lot of very nice people who've
done very,
very bad things that conflict with my
deeply held
conceptions of justice or sexual
equality or acceptable practice or
religious views.
Um,
a lot of gray areas in travel,
um,
but I think that on balance
the world is filled with people doing
the best they can,
you know,
we love their kids and you know,
would like to,
you know,
put on a clean shirt every morning and
live their lives in the little dignity
and have access to food and water.
Hope.
I'm
just like everybody else.
Uninhibited.
Creative freedom is something that I've
been incredibly fortunate to have for
the better part of my entire television
career.
Unlike anyone else I know of in
television.
I've been free to do whatever I want to
make the shows I want,
anywhere I want,
with whom I want it in any style I want.
So I,
at first I don't know any other way and
by now I won't have it any other way.
Life is good.
Why settle for less?
And by the same token,
when you're given that much freedom and
you're,
you have essentially no interference,
nothing but support behind you.
Um,
what you don't want to do is get lazy
and bored and sloppy.
To me,
I'd much rather not make tv at all or
make even unsuccessful tv that make
competent television.
You know,
it's very easy to make a conventional
travel or food show at this point.
It's,
it's like shooting corn.
It's the same shot sequence at the same
sort of limited a terminology.
Uh,
you know,
how all of their little pieces work
where you have to start and where you
have to add.
Um,
I detest competent workman like
storytelling and I'm always very,
you know,
the Times that we,
we,
we do that.
I'm,
I'm very unhappy with that.
I'd rather I'd rather fail.
Now.
I've been fired many times by in my
cooking career.
Uh,
I've been fired a number of times.
I was not a particularly good chef.
I had a lot of problems at various
points in my career with narcotics.
Um,
I was very deservedly a fired on a
number of occasions.
Um,
but I mean if you're talking about
failure,
you know,
I accepted failure as a chef because I
was at various times a bad chef or even
a bad person
these days.
If I fail,
it's because I tried to do something and
did not succeed or I,
I just was not able to do,
uh,
what I hope to do or wanted to do.
Or maybe I tried to do something that is
clearly in retrospect didn't work,
but I would much rather than that I
would much rather fail gloriously then
not venture,
not try.
I'm not in,
as I said before,
I'm not interested in,
in competent making,
telling,
telling stories with,
with competence.
I'm looking at them with some style and
originality and some creativity that is
interesting to me and the people I work
with
and there have been times that,
that,
that has resulted in failure,
a beating.
It didn't work.
It didn't communicate anything like what
I wanted to.
Often the story I think I'm going to get
ends up being another story entirely
that's even better.
We're very different.
That's good.
But there are other times where I just
failed miserably,
you know,
I tried to do with cecily shell again
and it was not good.
It did not capture the place.
It did not,
didn't show us anything of value.
It,
it did not live up to its subtlety and
beauty of its subject.
Um,
and then there are,
there are shows where some people are
just going to hate it.
They just don't like the style.
They think it's self indulgent.
They don't get it.
But that's kind of failure.
I like
no,
a powerful reaction one way or the
other,
uh,
infinitely preferable to me than
pleasing everybody.
If you,
if every.
If I walk into a room where everybody
agrees with me,
I find that frightening and dismayed and
pouring.
It's fucking my answer.
That question stems from my history is
an addict.
I'm a lot of other addicts look in the
mirror every day and did not see
somebody worth saving.
Even at my worst,
there was a level of vanity.
I guess I look in the mirror and saw
somebody who,
somebody deep in there,
regardless of how low I was,
my circumstances,
I had a high enough opinion of myself
that I thought,
um,
it's worth going forward.
I think a lot of people in a similar
situation for whatever reason,
look in the mirror and see somebody
unworthy of good things
and allow themselves or excuse
a downward spiral because they don't
really believe
in their basic work I did.
You know?
So that's vanity.
I think it's the same drive that allows
me to tell stories in books and on tv
because let's face it,
anybody who writes a book or ged with
the notion that they have a story worth
telling that people might want to listen
to.
You're really already by definition now
as sort of an aberrant personality and a
monster of self regard.
This is a very reasonable attitude.
I have a unique,
I have a story that you will want to
listen to for 10 minutes.
Why would any reasonable?
And I might make a living doing that.
So you might even want to pay for that
story.
To the point that I could make a living
doing that rather than washing dishes
or,
or preparing meals
that's not normal.
That takes something and I don't know
whether that's,
you know,
that's often a very much at odds with,
with,
you know,
being a functioning well rounded good
person in the conventional sense,
uh,
that kind of vanity and narcissism,
self regard,
self importance and cheerful willingness
to examine your and share your feelings.
No,
I think Fran Liebowitz said at one
point,
you know,
if you're,
if you're sharing your feelings,
you don't need that.
It's not sharing that's leaking.
When that book came out,
it was immediately a best seller and it
changed my life overnight.
Overnight.
I was desperately and debt
hadn't paid my rent on time.
Ever
had owed Amex for 10 years without
making a single payment owed.
The irs hadn't even filed,
was in very,
very,
very insecure place.
At Age 44.
Suddenly people were offering me things,
offering the opportunities.
I think if I did,
I was old enough and I fucked up enough
already that I just said,
you know,
I realize this is a lucky break,
was unlikely to get another,
so I'd be very careful.
Choices
in that environment was very determined
to not fuck up.
Oh,
I didn't go for easy money.
I didn't grab the first thing.
I did not
give food,
network the show they wanted
and I said no a lot.
So what seemed like a lot of money.
Well look what's good for you in the
short run is not necessarily good for
you in the long run.
You know you're starting out as a
writer.
You've written one book and somebody got
a TV show and somebody offers you a
million dollars to represent that
antidiarrhea medication.
Well,
that's a lot of money in the short run,
but you're always going to be that guy
with the shits.
I'm admittedly,
I'm a very contradictory impulses here.
I'm,
I'm old school and a lot of ways I think
you should at least know how to make
beef Bourguignon correctly according to
the original recipe.
To the degree that anything can be
authentic,
uh,
you should know how to,
you know,
some dishes to me,
like a conduit or a traditional Italian
pastas.
I get really pissy if people riff on
them,
you know,
you put chicken in a carbon,
are you lost me,
it's unforgivable sin against God.
But on the other hand,
you know,
the guys who came out of Blues and R and
B,
uh,
who turned out to be Jimi Hendrix,
you know,
there are people who can riff on and
improvise on classics and create whole
new,
wonderful worlds.
And what is authentic is mostly meaning
the city.
When the tomato is not authentic Italian
and it came from the new world of
Chinese food is always evolving.
So it was protective.
It instinctively hostile to new as I can
be a.
I know too many really creative chefs
and I understand the changing world.
Is it pleasurable,
I guess is the benchmark for the.
If you're going to mess with a classic,
are you making something more dazzling
that says,
look at me and how smart I am?
Or are you in some way improving?
It is it pleasurable?
Is it chicken Caesar more pleasurable
than a plain Cesar?
I think not.
I think the chicken takes away,
but that's my opinion.
I'm relentlessly,
pathologically a punctual,
I think.
I think that comes from all those years
as a chef that is a,
more importantly,
as a cook,
you know,
can you showed up late as a cook?
You're letting your people down in a
very tangible way.
Somebody else has to physically do the
work,
do the setup,
or you lose the shift or you get fired
as a chef cooks and showed up late who
are disorganized.
You couldn't keep a lot of stuff going
on in their heads.
They failed and when they fail,
we all went down with them.
So I am a relentlessly,
you know,
possibly either unhealthfully,
anal retentive,
uh,
you know,
obsessive compulsive,
uh,
you know,
cleaning up after my,
when I'm cooking,
I'm cleaning up after myself constantly.
I keep things organized.
I write lists,
I keep my schedule up to date.
I am never late.
And as part of that,
if I say to you,
I'm going to meet you tomorrow at 12
minutes after five to see John Wick
seven,
uh,
I will be there at five.
Oh,
two hanging out across the street,
discreetly observing to see what time
you show up and I'll be making some very
important decisions based on your
arrival time.
It's a curse and a blessing.
But I think everything important I ever
learned,
I learned that I learned as a,
as a,
as a dishwasher and as a cook,
a,
you show up on time,
you organize,
you get,
you know,
you stay organized and clean up after
yourself or you think about the people
you work with.
You respect the people you work with.
Um,
and like I said,
you do the best you can.